okay good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
first off i want to thank everyone for
being out here this afternoon
because we as a police department we
need the community's help to solve this
case
so on march 22nd at approximately 3
30 in the morning kashif brown arrived
at the circle k directly behind me
and was in the process of filling up his
car with gas
when kashif arrived at the parking uh at
the circle k
he started the his car or started
filling up his car with gas he went
inside to make some small
purchases and then when he walked
outside
a car pulled up alongside of him that
car is approximately around 2015
gray chrysler 300. the driver of that
car is an
unidentified black male who exited the
car in what we
think was an attempted robbery
at that point the suspect approached
kashif
and fired multiple rounds striking and
killing him
at the gas pumps directly behind me
he then got into the vehicle and fled
from the scene
what we have learned is that the vehicle
was driven again by an unidentified
black male
and we know there was a black female
passenger
inside the car this afternoon
immediately after this press conference
we are going to release surveillance
video
that captures the vehicle and it also
captures the shooting
i urge everyone to please watch the
video
and reach out to us because you could
have the answer that would give this
family behind me closure
and hold the person responsible for this
horrific crime
and hold them accountable watch the
video that's going to be provided
any information that you have regardless
of how
small you can reach out to crime
stoppers there is reward money available
you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
i'm going to let the kashish mother
speak for a few minutes and then i'll
step back to the podium
and answer any questions
hi i'm kashif brown's mom
that was my oldest son
he was a sibling of seven or s
yeah he was a sibling of seven children
um
he has he has a family three
beautiful girls and a wife
and
[Music]
i just need help trying to solve his
case because
he didn't deserve what he got
he was a good he was a good guy he was a
good soul
good spirit and he made you laugh
and um i just
his girls would never get to grow with
that dad
he was always there with his family
he wasn't in the streets or nothing
he would go to work go back home
be with his family and i'm just
pleased if you have any information just
please
give it to the detectives please
i love my son very much and it's still
unbelievable that he's gone
i it's hard to believe
still i'm trying to wrap my head around
it
and i have to go pick up my son's ashes
today
and um
she's 100 percent right he did not
deserve this
he i investigate a lot of crime
in this valley and let me tell you he
was going to a gas station at three
o'clock in the morning on his way to
work
when someone shot and killed him
in a robbery please i urge anybody
watch the video look for anything that
you
see that could help us identify and
bring closure to this family
with that i will give a cup take a
couple questions and again i stress
there is reward money available through
crime stoppers
and your information is completely
anonymous when you go through crime
stoppers
so with that again i'll take a couple
questions caitlyn
it is very difficult right now so you're
gonna see from the video surveillance
that
the the car had actually pulled into the
parking lot we believe for about 10
minutes prior to
approaching kashif when he parked his
car we think that that
the suspect was either casing the store
for a robbery or casing anybody else
pulling up to the pumps
so we do have video surveillance of the
car
we just can't make out the license plate
on the vehicle
and there's no link to him and that's to
to go to your point is there's
you know as an investigator you
typically on a homicide investigation
look for a link
here it's a complete random incident so
there is no link and that is why we urge
the public
to reach out to us and help us solve
this case
so from witness information we again we
know the driver was a black male we know
that the
female was a black female passenger they
were both sitting
sitting on the side of the business for
about 10 minutes before the robbery and
murder
attempt robbery and murder took place so
that is all the information that we have
so you know i know for a fact that
there's somebody out in the community
that has the information that will
bring closure to this family
so i'm not going to get into the
specific aspect
of forensic evidence that was found at
the scene there
we have forensic evidence that we are
examining and we're going to
you know look at every piece of forensic
evidence that would help solve this case
but again
the reason i have you guys out here
today is we need help
and your viewers could hold the piece of
the puzzle that can solve this crime
how unusual is a crime like this
completely random like this not even
like
again it's extremely random in the sense
that you have
a robbery that has turned into a murder
and
with no link it does provide some
difficulties for us as
investigators right and they weren't
able to successfully
take anything right correct there was
nothing taken from him
so that's why we're saying it we believe
it was an attempt robbery just by the
suspect's actions
prior to the incident and what led up to
it so thank you guys the family will be
available after the conference
if you have any other questions from
this again thank you very much